[Musik]
auch bei super höher war wohl nicht der
seit sechs uhr morgens weil ich dachte
ihr treten massenhaft leute meine neue
partei eintreten so richtig dass
politische systeme auf links sitzt mir
alle zu hause auf dem sofa
ja weiß ich auch nicht mehr weiter aber
ich habe vor ein paar tagen habe ich
hier diese umfrage von forsa sie haben
gefragt welcher partei trauen sie zu mit
dem problem in deutschland am besten
fertig zu werden wir haben fast 50
prozent gesagt keiner partei also 50
prozent trauen keiner partei
zurückziehen probleme in deutschland zu
lösen so und jetzt versteht er
hoffentlich warum ich meine neue partei
genannt habe keiner partei ist es gut
weil der wille jetzt schon zugetraut die
probleme zu lösen hätte gerade gemacht
hier fehlt nicht möglich
oder
gar keine partei kann mich verstehen
endlich oder du hast keine wahl wer
keine partei
ist geil war
ja dann hab ich 100000 euro angeboten
weil ich gedacht er würde wäre michael
czupalla es hat keinen bock drauf
man muss manchmal wirklich sagen
deutschland wir müssen reden auch mal
ganz im ernst
in deutschlands bürger in und
deutschlands politik da man hat das
gefühl die sind nun auch wegen der
kinder zusammen magnet aneinander vorbei
geredet schlecht übereinander
zärtlichkeiten lange her ganze 30
prozent sagen demokratie bringt noch
nicht vertrauen in die bundesregierung
hatten im februar noch fette 18 prozent
18 prozent fußpilz hat mehr fans und die
unzufriedenheit in der politik die zieht
sich mit kleinen unterschieden durch
alle altersgruppen viele leute gehen gar
nicht mehr wählen im durchschnitt liegt
die wahlbeteiligung im neuen jahrtausend
etwa 15 prozentpunkte tiefer als noch in
den siebziger
mehr als 14 millionen menschen haben
sich bei der letzten bundestagswahl
gesagt war es bundestag dafür solch eine
ruhe ansehen ohne mich
und 65 prozent der nichtwähler sagen die
parteien und politiker mal was sie
wollen das absurde ist ja aus
nichtwähler perspektive stimmt das immer
keine politische band ich ich hab jetzt
zwar die wahl gewonnen aber es gibt
schon viele die haben mich nicht gewählt
dann mache ich was die wollen niemand
richtet sich nach denen die nicht wählen
und dann gibt's sogar leute sind genauso
frustriert wie die nichtwähler gehen
aber trotzdem wählen und zwar aus rache
einer umfrage von infratest dimap nach
haben bei der landtagswahl in nrw 50
prozent der fdp wähler die partei nicht
gewählt weil sie von deren politischen
position überzeugt waren sondern weil
sie von allen anderen parteien
enttäuscht waren auch die fdp
33 nicht aus überzeugung sondern aus
enttäuschung endlich verstehe ich warum
leute fdp will
jeder dritte mensch der fdp wählt denkt
sich deutschland ist so scheiße die
bestrafe ich mit der fdp ohne die
enttäuschten wäre die fdp nicht im
landtag in nrw christian lindner ist der
täter wohl in der politik die leute
wollen dich dafür dass du ein ekel bis
sie ist oder aber wir drehen wir so viel
darüber wie unzufrieden wir in
deutschland mit der politik sind aber
was ist das überhaupt polizei politik
ist sind ja alles alle dinge die wir uns
als menschen ausgedacht haben um als
gesellschaft entscheidungen zu treffen
also man kann sagen nicht nur olaf
scholz zulieferteilen der bundestag ist
das politik sondern wir sind politik
also einfach schon wenn wir uns
gemeinsam einig sind dass wir ein
brecher bestrafen aber nicht leute die
zum beispiel sagen zum bleistift
wobei ich da gern noch mal drüber reden
will aber statt sich selbst als teil von
politik zu sehen als wichtigsten teil
sogar neben viel politik nur noch als
service war so als service den man mit
einer schlechten bewertung geschlafen
kann wenn man unzufrieden ist nur zwei
von fünf sternen weil demokratie auf den
fotos echt besser ausgesehen hat wie zum
beispiel das ist olaf scholz in
originalgröße
[Musik]
also eigentlich sind wir alle für
politik verantwortlich
wird sagen wieso ein hausmeister also
zugegebenermaßen sehr großes haus und
die meisten sachen die da kaputtgehen
sind so fiese sanitär sachen wo so
braune dinge raus spritzen aber hey es
ist unser haus und ich glaube es gibt in
deutschland aus dem teufelskreis je mehr
du politik für deinen service erhält
desto schlechter wird der service kennt
man aus wgs wenn du denkst dann müsst
ihr mal wieder jemand putzen lässt du
dreckiger wird die wohnung je weniger
leute bei dem conti mitmachen desto
schlechter wird die demokratie und die
schlechte die demokratie dass sie
weniger machen mit wer nur alle vier
jahre einmal am glücksrad dreht ist
natürlich schnell genervt wenn er dann
nur einen kugelschreiber bekommt aber
häufiger mal mitmacht der so geholfen da
darf man drehen und irgendwann bekommt
man dann vielleicht sogar den absoluten
hauptgewinn achtung achtung vor
jede kleine vorzulesen oder aber sie hat
noch nie etwas gewonnen ja und klar
müssen wir uns regelmäßig ein bisschen
kümmern um unsere demokratie
er ist liegt ja auch daran dass ist
andere ausnutzen wer es nicht tut wir
leben ja nicht nur in der demokratie
sondern vor allem im kapitalismus das
heißt ja also das jetzt nicht nur die
marke von carsten maschmeyer das parfüm
sondern auch unser wirtschaftssystem und
da gibt es den freien markt und der
macht eigentlich das reiche noch mehr
geld bekommen also allein 2020 wurden
70.000 neue menschen fielen am
spanischen millionär 70.000 insgesamt
gibt es 16 millionen deutsche die eine
million euro oder mehr haben jetzt kann
man fragen wer weiß denn schlimm daran
dass reiche gibt sind ein auf zwei
prozent in deutschland ist doch
demokratie die bringen genauso
interessen ein wie leute die weniger
geld habe und absolut ja vielen vielen
dank
und da muss man auch mal sagen nicht
alle die reich sind will komplette voll
assis da muss man mal die reichen von
carsten maschmeyer in schutz nehmen
problematisch wird es nur wenn reiche
viel mehr einfluss haben als andere weil
sie firmen haben weil sie ihnen anteile
an zeitung gehören weil sie in einer
demokratie war lobbyismus viel mehr
einfluss nehmen können aber wir als
bürgerinnen und wähler innen sind doch
eigentlich die größte und mächtigste
lobby von allen vielleicht müssen wir
wollen deswegen auch mal als lobby
veranstaltung für uns begreifen also die
bevölkerung muss auch immer wieder sagen
das ist jetzt wichtig es konnte
irgendwann keine atomkraft lobby
verhindern dass deutschland aus der
kernenergie aussteigt oder dass man
vielleicht doch noch mal mehr auf e
autos setzt man muss sich immer wieder
organisieren wie die quere community die
beiräte gesagt hat verrückte idee aber
könnt ihr uns schwulen und lesben
vielleicht wie normale menschen
behandeln weil wir sind normale menschen
her cool danke aber wie sind wir hier
gelandet so wie kommt das dass wir uns
für gar nichts mehr zuständig fühlen
erst recht nicht für politik der
soziologe andreas beck wird es hat zu
dem thema geforscht und sagt stark
vereinfacht wir sind nicht bei 3sat es
liegt am neoliberalismus und links
liberalismus und kurz gesagt wir haben
zu viel bock auf freiheit weil wir
spätestens in den siebzigern kein bock
mehr hatten aufmüpfigkeit und
spießigkeit haben wir uns eine welt
geschaffen die mehr wert auf
individualismus liegt und weniger auf
starke gemeinschaft und die grundidee
jeder kann leben wie er will hauptsache
er hat in der fußgängerzone eine rose an
ist super gut aber es klappt nicht also
wenn jeder von uns darüber vergisst was
die voraussetzung dafür ist gesellschaft
nämlich leider ich wünsche es wieder
anders ganz ehrlich also jedes mal wenn
so ein junggesellenabschied im ece
stattfindet bekommt meine grund
solidarität ist aber es hilft ja nicht
erst wenn annette und dirk das
bedingungslose grundeinkommen abfahren
hat die idee eine chance wir sind selber
schuld dass wir ständig von der politik
enttäuscht sind
unangenehmer gedanke also gerade für uns
bei der heute schon da hilft nur nach
vorne gucken hier gerade hier meinen
stop shop die ist die straße
ja und geht nach vorne gucken und da
muss man lösungen suchen und blätter mal
leute die ahnung fragen wie es
weitergehen soll zum beispiel den
politikwissenschaftler felix heidenreich
der meinte aufgabe von politiker innen
ist es auch die leute zu hause nicht
mehr als konsumenten anzusprechen
sondern als teil haben die bürger sehr
guter gedanke ich kann dieses
wahlkampfschlager nicht mehr hören wenn
politiker sagen wir als partei machen
ihnen ein angebot bis zum supermarkt
prospekt oder was das politiker innen
das machen dann natürlich auch was damit
zu tun dass wir es hören wollen ich
meine was klingt besser jemand der sagt
leute füße relax ich kümmere mich darum
einfach nur ein kreuz und es wird geil
oder immer gesagt erneutes komplizierten
oder müssen wir natürlich an einem bock
auf das all-inclusive-angebot das
quatsch ist und genau das ist das
problem
niemand von uns muss in der partei
antreten oder berufspolitik machen oft
reicht es schon einfach mal andere leute
von einer guten idee zu überzeugen oder
die idee ins system zu tragen ich lass
mal vor einem jahr zusammen mit leuten
wie haben sich wahnsinnig darüber
aufgeregt dass es bei ihnen in der
nachbarschaft zwar 100 parkplätze für
autos gibt aber keine lastenräder unter
haben wir uns auch schwierig überhaupt
politik die autolobby deutsche
stadtplanung und dann kam irgendwann
eine schlaue freundin dazu und hat
gefragt erläutert das problem dass sie
da habt habt ihr eben dem schon mal
davon erzählt bei der stadt und keinem
von uns war das in den sinn gekommen
nach fünf minuten kugeln haben wir sogar
gemerkt beim zuständigen amt gibt es
jemanden der nur für so was zuständig
ist für wünsche von bürger innen ein
jahr später stehen da stellplätze nur
weil sich drei leute hingesetzt haben
ein bisschen zeit investieren haben
jetzt keinen schluss ger das kommt schön
tiefgründig
gut oder
bisschen 3sat ein klein bisschen ist
auch manchmal ganz geil
nein ich mache hier gar nichts mehr
bevor ihr nicht den kanal abonniert und
ein leica last
ich hab die schnauze voll
loslassen abo da